[Musik]
der naheosten ist wieder einmal in aller
Munde und es ist Israel das wieder
einmal im Mittelpunkt des Konflikts
steht als ob dort alles in einer ewigen
Dauerschleife gefangen sei ja meine
Lieben Zuschauer Israel befindet sich
wieder im Krieg der Krieg zwischen
Israel und Hamas erreicht einen
kritischen Punkt Israels Truppen haben
das alschiva Krankenhaus im Gazastreifen
eingekreist das als Hauptquartier der
chamas gilt zum Glück für das Hebräische
Land gleicht dieser Krieg nicht den in
der 60er oder 70er Jahre als mehrere
arabische Länder Israel plötzlich
Angriffen im Moment erinnert die
Situation eher an die Kriege die Israel
1982 und 2006 gegen den Libanon geführt
hat um die PLO bzw die hisbalah
auszulöschen aber was wäre wenn ich euch
sagen würde dass dieses ganze Chaos zu
einem offenen Krieg zwischen mehreren
Ländern führen könnte das wird euch
wahrscheinlich nicht sonderlich
überraschen schließlich wäre es nicht
das erste Mal dass so etwas im Nahen
Osten passiert aber lass mich euch eine
Frage stellen welches Land könnte das
erste sein das dem jüdischen Staat den
Krieg erklärt nun höchstwahrscheinlich
natürlich jenes das bereits an die
türklopft die wung des Irans an die UN
wenn Israel in Gaza einmarschiert werden
wir eingreifen wir haben unseren Finger
am Abzug in der Tat meine Lieben
Zuschauer hat der Iran bereits einige
Warnungen über einen möglichen Krieg
gegen Israel ausgesendet und das ist
keine
Kleinigkeit der Iran ist neben Israel
und Saudiarabien eine der drei
wichtigsten Region almächte im Nahen
Osten und verfügt über beträchtliche
militärische Kapazitäten während dies
auf internationaler Ebene allerdings ein
großer Schock wäre waren Analysten
bereits vor einem besonders
beunruhigenden Risiko sollte der IRA
nämlich gegen Israel in den Krieg ziehen
würden die USA mit Sicherheit in den
Konflikt hineingezogen werden und für
viele wäre dies der Auftakt zu einem
wirklich großen Krieg diese Entwicklung
hat uns hier bei visualpolitik
veranlasst uns ein paar Fragen zu
stellen wie sehen überhaupt die
Beziehungen zwischen dem Iran und den
USA aus warum sind die USA so besorgt
über eine mögliche iranische
Intervention in Israel würden die Amis
die Islamische Republik tatsächlich
angreifen und was noch wichtiger ist
würden sie damit Erfolg haben heute
werden wir all diese Fragen natürlich
beantworten vorher habe ich aber noch
eine wichtige Frage an euch erinnert ihr
euch noch an die Schräge holzgernwerbung
mit der wir euch vor zwei Monaten zum
Lachen gebracht haben falls ihr sie
verpasst haben solltet verlinke ich euch
das Video mit ihr oben rechts hinter dem
i-symbol wie gesagt viele Zuschauer
waren von unserem kurzen Clip damals
ziemlich begeister und wie wir von
holzgn gehört haben anschließend auch
von ihren schönen Produkten damals
wussten wir aber noch nicht dass es
jetzt noch besser kommt denn stellt euch
vor während der Black weeks bietet
Holzkern unserer Community ein noch
wesentlich besseres Angebot um auch
wirklich alle von den Vorzügen ihrer
tollen Uhren und Accessoires zu
überzeugen und wie sieht dieses Angebot
aus nun ganz einfach passend zur
Vorweihnachtszeit gibt es den perfekten
geschenkerabatt falls du nämlich zwei
Produkte kaufst bekommst du satte 50%
Rabatt auf den zweiten günstigeren
Artikel auf diese Weise kannst du deine
Lieben besonders preiswert erfreuen oder
man nutzt die höchsten Rabatte des
Jahres einfach für ein Geschenk an sich
selbst z.B ein holzkernset das man
sowieso schon lange im Auge hatte fakt
ist so gut wie jeder von uns hier in der
visualpolitikredaktion hat sich schon in
mestens zwei wunderschöne holzkernuhren
verliebt und jetzt muss man sich nicht
länger quälen denn man kann super
günstig beide wählen schon beim
Auspacken des liebevoll gestalteten
Päckchens merkt man dass die
österreichische Firma Holzkern ihr
ganzes Herzblut darin steckt dass
wirklich jede Facette perfekt sitzt und
gleichzeitig herrlich natürlich ist die
optimale Verbindung aus Präzision und
natürlicher Eleganz was will man mehr
von einer Uhr sofort fallen einem
natürlich die hochwertigen Materialien
auf aus denen die Uhr gefertigt ist ihre
Maserung Marmorierung und das schillern
von holzstein und Perlmut jedes Stück
ist von Natur aus ein Unikat die
Naturverbundenheit von Holzkern zeigt
sich jedoch nicht nur in ihren Produkten
sondern auch darin dass ihre Herstellung
Verpackung und die Lieferketten so
nachhaltig wie möglich gestaltet sind
also lasass dir diese letzte große
Rabattaktion vor Weihnachten nicht
entgehen und erfreut dich und deine
Lieben mit dem idealen Geschenk der
Einzigartigkeit einer holzkernuhr und
oder mit einem wunderschönen Accessoire
aus dem ebenfalls schön natürlich
gestalteten Schmucksortiment aber zögere
nicht zu lange denn das ganze ist
selbstverständlich versandkostenfrei und
den tollen 1+1 Rabatt erhältst du nur
vom 14 bis 20 November 2023 Folge hierzu
einfach dem Link den du in der
Videobeschreibung findest so und wenn du
deine Weihnachtseinkäufe erledigt hast
lass uns wieder in unser Thema
eintauchen
aufgepasst in freiem
Fall dass der Iran und die USA einander
verachten ist nichts neues das ist schon
seit mehreren Jahrzehten der Fall
allerdings war das nicht immer so es gab
sogar eine Zeit in der sie gute Freunde
waren denn noch änderte sich alles mit
der islamischen Revolution von
1979 10 Jahre nach der Unabhängigkeit
des Irans im Jahr 1943 begann die USA
sich den Iran anzunähern nachdem sie
eine Gruppe iranischer Militäroffiziere
geholfen hatten einen Staatsstreich zu
inszenieren und Premierminister Mohammed
mosadek zu stürzen nadem diese die
angl-persische Ölgesellschaft
verstaatlichtt hatte von diesem Moment
an kam Shah Risa pachlavi an die Macht
der in der iranischen Bevölkerung
äußerst unbeliebt war aber von ankel Sam
stark unterstützt wurde zu diesem
Zeitpunkt begann die Freundschaft
zwischen dem Iran und den USA zu
erblühen so erteilte der Schar 1954
US-amerikanischen Ölfirmen eine
25-jährige Erlaubnis einen Teil des
verstaatlichen Öls auszubeuten später im
Jahr 1957 unterzeichneten die beiden ein
Abkommen über nukleare Zusammenarbeit
das die Grundlage für das iranische
Atomprogramm bildete es ermöglichte dem
Land 1967 seinen ersten Atomreaktor zu
bauen und nicht nur das 1972 während
eines Besuchs von präsident Richard
Nixon beim Schar versprachen die USA den
Iran den Kauf von nichtnuklearen
Waffensystemen zu ermöglichen wenn er
sich verpflichten würde die Interessen
der USA gegen die Sowjetunion im Nahen
Osten zu
schützen allerdings kam dann eben das
Jahr 1979 und die Islamische Revolution
stellte diese schöne Freundschaft auf
den
Kopf Ayatollah romeni kam an die Macht
und der Iran wurde eine islamische
Republik und diese erklärte die USA
zusammen mit Israel zum Hauptfeind von
da an ging es mit den Beziehungen
ungebremst Berg ab in den ersten beiden
Jahren des islamischen Regimes zwischen
1979 und 81 mussten sich die USA z.B mit
der Geiselnahme von Amerikanern im Iran
auseinandersetzen später unterstützte
Washington den Irak im Krieg den Saddam
Hussein zwischen 1980 und 88 gegen das
Regime der ayatollas führte in der
Zwischenzeit haben die USA nicht
gezögert Sanktionen gegen den Iran zu
verhängen und im Jahr 2002 kurz nach den
Terroranschlägen auf das World Trade
Center in New York zählte der damalige
Präsident Bush den Iran zusammen mit dem
Irak und Nordkorea zur Achse des
Bösen
so verschlechterten sich die Beziehungen
immer mehr allerdings gab es in all
diesen Spannungen auch einen Moment der
Ruhe im Jahr 2015 10 Jahre nach der
Entdeckung des geheimen iranischen
Atomprogramms unterzeichneten die USA
die Islamische Republik und andere
europäische Länder den berühmten
gemeinsamen umfassenden Aktionsplan ein
Plan der die nuklearen Möglichkeiten des
Irans einschränkte und ihn einer
strengen über unterwarf ein Plan der nur
wenige Jahre später in sich zusammenfiel
ihr seht also dass die Beziehungen
zwischen dem Iran und den USA in den
letzten vierzen von Spannungen geprägt
waren ja es stimmt es gab eine
vorübergehende Atempause aber die
Realität ist dass die Feindseligkeiten
nie wirklich aufgehört haben in den
letzten Jahren hat sich die Situation
sogar noch weiter verschlimmert und wie
weit wirklich das schauen wir uns jetzt
genau an passt gut
auf Probleme über
Probleme
sicherlich gab es viele die 2018 dachten
dass der Iran und die USA mit dem
gemeinsamen umfassenden Aktionsplan
zumindest einen Raum der Ruhe betreten
hätten wenn uns die Welt in den letzten
Jahren allerdings etwas gezeigt hat dann
dass wir nichts für selbstverständlich
halten können und genau das ist mit der
scheinbaren Ruhe zwischen den USA und
dem Iran passiert die schließlich in die
Brüche ging Trump gibt iranabkommen auf
dass er lange verachtet hat damit gab
Donald Trump das Programm auf das für
einen gewissen Frieden zwischen den USA
und im Iran gesorgt hatte der ehemalige
US-Präsident wollte einfach keine leeren
Drohungen des radikalislamischen Regimes
mehr dulden so drückte erst damals aus
die USA verhängten schnell neue
Sanktionen gegen das Regime in der
Hoffnung dass der Iran sein Atomprogramm
einstellen würde aber ratet mal was der
Iran seitdem getan
hat er hat sich im Grunde genommen gar
nicht mehr an das Abkommen gehalten das
Land der ayatollas hat die
Urananreicherung so sehr intensiviert
dass die die Internationale
Atomenergiebehörde 2019 warnte der Iran
habe bereits eine anreicherungsquote von
84% erreicht um euch eine Vorstellung
davon zu geben man braucht um eine
Atomwaffe zu bauen zu 90% angereichertes
Uran mit anderen Worten 2019 waren sie
bereits kurz davor dies zu erreichen
deshalb gab es viele Stimmen die
alarmchlugen wir haben nicht mehr den
Sicherheitsabstand von einem Jahr bis
zum Durchbruch des Atomwaffenprogramms
der Iran steht zwei Wochen vor dem
Durchbruch einen Schritt davon entfernt
90% angereichertes ur an zu erreichen
eine ausreichende Menge für eine Bombe
um die Bombe in eine Waffe umzuwandeln
und die Anpassung an einen
raketensprengkopf für eine Rakete
abzuschließen sind etwas zwei weitere
Jahre nötig angesichts dessen hat die
Regierung beiden die versucht hat die
Verhandlungen mit dem Iran über das
atomabkommen wieder aufzunehmen die
Sanktionen gegen das iranische Regime
fortgesetzt und versucht es
international weiter zu isolieren dies
hat jedoch nur dazu geführt dass
Freundschaften gestärkt wurden die die
USA lieber Schwächen würden wie z.B die
Freundschaft des Irans mit
Russland
obwohl Iran engere Beziehungen zu China
bevorzugt hätte haben sich die
internationalen Sanktionen als
unangenehmes Hindernis für diese
Beziehungen erwiesen da China nicht
riskieren möchte den umfangreichen
Handel mit den westlichen Ländern zu
verlieren aus diesem Grund hat sich der
Iran dafür entschieden die Beziehungen
zu Russland zu stärken einem anderen
internationalen Paria der ebenfalls von
einer Reihe von Sanktionen betroffen ist
ursprünglich bestand die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen diesen beiden Ländern vor allem
im Energiebereich der Krieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine hat diese
Zusammenarbeit allerdings auf andere
strategische Bereiche ausgeweitet schaut
es euch an ukrainekrieg USA sagen dass
der Iran jetzt Russlands wichtigster
militärischer Unterstützer ist seit dem
Beginn der russischen Invasion in der
Ukraine hat der Iran nach Angaben der
ukrainischen Regierung etwa 2400 drohen
nach Russland geschickt in diesem Fall
handelt es sich um kamikas drohen der
Modelle shahib 131 und 136 die die
russischen Bemühungen in der Ukraine vor
allem durch ihr gutes
Preisleistungsverhältnis unterstützen
jede dieser drohen kostet in der
Herstellung etwa 2000$ aber ihr Abschuss
kostet die Ukraine im Durchschnitt
zwischen 14000 und 15 000$ aus diesem
Grund haben sich sowohl der Iran als
auch Russland verpflichtet eine
drohfabrik in Russland selbst zu bauen
okay soweit so schlecht der Iran ist
also äußerst hilfsbereit gegenüber
Russland aber was hat eigentlich Teran
von seiner Annährung an Moskau nun ich
denke wir können sagen dass dieser
Schritt des iranischen Regimes eher eine
langfristige Investition darstellt ja es
stimmt der Iran wird moderne
Kampfflugzeuge Hubschrauber und
Flugabwehrsysteme erhalten aber im
Moment braucht Russland alle seine
Waffen für sich selbst der Iran ist auch
daran interessiert zu lernen wie er die
westlichen Sanktionen umgehen kann so
wie es Russland getan hat vor allem aber
sucht der Iran in Russland Schutz vor
internationalen Organisationen und vor
allem Schutz vor den USA und der
Europäischen
Union dennoch ist die größte Sorge der
US-Regierung angesichts der Lage im
Nahen Osten und in Israel vielleicht
weder das iranische Atomprogramm noch
die Freundschaft mit Russland sondern
die Verbündeten die der Iran in in der
Region hat ihr müsst verstehen wenn der
Iran ein Land angreifen will tut er das
nicht direkt sondern über terroristische
proxyruppen die er stark finanziert das
beste Beispiel dafür ist die hisbolla
die hisbolla über die wir euch auf
diesem Kanal bereits berichtet haben ist
eine libanesische Terrorgruppe und
politische Partei die während des
Bürgerkriegs zwischen 1975 und 1990
entstanden ist und jedes Jahr tausende
von Raketen und Hunderte von Millionen
Dollar aus dem Iran erhält die hisbolla
ist zu Irans wichtigsten Verbündeten im
Nahen Osten geworden denn sie
kontrolliert fast alle Gebiete im
Libanon ein Land das an Israel grenzt
und in letzter Zeit intensivieren sich
ihre Auseinandersetzungen mit Israel
nordgrenzer erhitzt sich durch neuen
Raketenbeschuss und Angriffe der
hesballah auf idfposten bisher hat es
die hesbalah weder gewagt die Israelis
in großem stitil anzugreifen noch Ihnen
den Krieg zu erklären allerdings hat
auch der Protagonist des neuen Konflikts
mit dem jüdischen Staat die Hamas enge
Verbindungen zum Iran es stimmt zwar
dass der schiitische Iran der
sunnitischen Hamas nicht so nah steht
wie der hisbalah aber dennoch reicht
ihre Zusammenarbeit bis in die 90er
Jahre zurück damals begann die
Islamische Republik die palästinänsische
Terrorgruppe mit jährlich mehr als 50
Millionen Dollar und Waffen zu
finanzieren die Sie über die hisbalah
schickte im Jahr 2012 begann die Hamas
dann Tel Aviv mit iranischen
Langstreckenraketen vom Typ Fader 5 zu
beschießen wie wir euch hier auf
visualpolitik berichtet haben glauben
viele dass der Iran hinter dem
Terroranschlag der Hamas auf Israel am 7
Oktober steckt aber was wäre wenn sich
tatsächlich bestätigen würde dass der
Iran hinter diesem Angriff auf Israel
steckt und was noch viel wichtiger ist
würden die USA in diesem Fall
militärisch den Iran angreifen genau das
nehmen wir jetzt unter die Lupe
aufgepasst der Iran das nächste Ziel der
USA wir haben euch ja bereits gesagt
dass es so einige Stimmen gibt die
behaupten es sei der Iran der hinter den
Anschlägen gegen Israel Anfang Oktober
steckt auch die israelische Regierung
glaubt fest daran und tatsächlich deutet
alles darauf hin dass dies der Fall ist
trotzdem behauptet man in Washington
dass es immer noch keine handfesten
Beweise für eine iranische Beteiligung
am Hamas Terroranschlag gibt doch egal
ob der Iran wirklich etwas damit zu tun
hatte oder nicht er hat deutlich gemacht
dass er nicht zögern würde einzugreifen
und einen offenen Konflikt gegen Israel
zu beginnen sollte das israelische
Vorgehen gegen die Hamas im Gazastreifen
anhalten für viele würde dies dazu
führen dass die USA direkt an Israels
Seite in den Konflikt eingreifen würden
und die Frage ist warum eigentlich wie
wichtig ist Israel für die USA ihr müsst
verstehen Israel ist nicht nur eine der
besten Verbündeten sondern seit
1967 auch von entscheidender
strategischer Bedeutung für die USA im
Kalten Krieg diente es als eine Art
Deich der Eindämmung ein vorgeschobener
Stützpunkt gegen den sowjetischen
Einfluss im Nahen Osten und heute ist es
bis zu einem gewissen Grad ein Puffer
gegen den islamischen Radikalismus und
die Mächte die die Interessen von ankel
Sam untergraben wollen Israel teilt mit
den Amis seine Erfahrungen und
nachrichtendienstlichen Informationen
und verfügt über eine spartanische
Streitmacht die auf alle Eventualitäten
vorbereitet ist deshalb ist ihre
wirtschaftliche militärische und
technologische Zusammenarbeit auch der
Art intensiv es besteht also kaum ein
Zweifel daran dass die USA in den
Konflikt eingreifen würden wenn der Iran
Israel angreifen würde aber wenn Israel
in den vergangenen Jahren mit dem Iran
aneinander geraten war war die Antwort
natürlich direkt israelisch und sie war
heftig 10 Mai 2018 Israel startet einen
massiven Militärschlag gegen iranische
Ziele in Syrien heutzutage geht die
amerikanische Sorge vor einem iranischen
Angriff auf Israel allerdings über einen
möglichen Raketenangriff hinaus jetzt
gibt es einen weiteren entscheidenden
Faktor der die USA und den gesamten
Nahen Osten in Atem hält ein möglicher
nuklearer
[Musik]
Iran experten weisen zwar darauf hin
dass der Iran bereits über genügend zu
90% angereichtes Uran verfüge aber sie
sie behaupten dass es immer noch
zwischen 6 und 24 Monaten dauern würde
bis er eine Atomwaffe entwickelt aber
selbst wenn uns die US-Geheimdienste
versichern dass der Iran sein
atomwaffenentwicklungsprogramm 2022
nicht wieder aufgenommen hat können wir
in Wirklichkeit nicht mit absoluter
Sicherheit sagen ob er nicht doch schon
eine Atomwaffe besitzt wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass seit dem Rückzug der USA
aus dem gemeinsamen umfassenden
Aktionsplan im Jahr 2018 die iranische
Transparenz in nuklearfragen gegen Null
gesunken ist und nicht nur das wir
müssen auch bedenken dass der Bau einer
Nuklearwaffe sehr gut unterirdisch
erfolgen kann s dass eine
satellitenanalyse nutzlos
ist wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist
Israel natürlich besonders besorgt über
diese Situation die die mit Abstand
größte existenzielle Bedrohung für das
Land darstellen könnte deshalb hat
ministerpräsidentan yahu auch schon vor
ein paar Monaten folgende Erklärung
abgegeben wie hält man einen
schuttenstat davon ab sich Atomwaffen zu
beschaffen ihr hattet einen der Saddam
Husseins Irak heißt er wurde mit
militärischer Gewalt gestoppt mit
unserer ihr hattet einen zweiten der
Syrien hieß und versuchte Atomwaffen zu
entwickeln und es wurde durch eine
militärische Aktion gestoppt unsere
dieses äußerst bedrohliche und
feindsillige Szenario mit dem Risiko
dass ein potenzieller nuklearer Iran
Israel angreifen könnte macht viele
Menschen in Washington
nervös und die Wahrheit ist dass das
Thema Iran immer heißer wird die
Beschlagnahme von Öltankern seine
Unterstützung für Russland seine
Beteiligung am Angriff auf Israel und
nun noch eine mögliche Atombombe es gibt
mehr als genug Gründe für eine
Eskalation der Lage tatsächlich erwegen
viele Analysten bereits die Möglichkeit
eines Eingreifens der USA wenn die
Gewalt in der Region eskalieren sollte
im nächsten Jahr finden die
US-Präsidentschaftswahlen statt und wie
wir wissen ist Donald Trump nicht gerade
jemand der gerne mit den mullas kuschelt
zumindest nicht so sehr wie die
Demokraten aber würde eine Intervention
im Iran wirklich erfolgreich sein
vorerst hat die Regierung beiden bereits
beschlossen sich auf einen möglichen
Konflikt
vorzubereiten die USA schicken einen
zweiten Flugzeugträger ins östliche
Mittelmeer die USS Eisenhauer wird sich
der USS Ford vor Israel anschließen wenn
die USA den Iran angreifen wollen
bräuchten sie natürlich viel mehr als
nur zwei Flugzeugträger aber es gibt
jede Menge us-ausrüstung in der Region
darunter einen riesigen
Luftwaffenstützpunkt in Qatar und wir
müssen bedenken dass der Iran das größte
Arsenal an ballistischen
Langstreckenraketen und drohen im Nahen
Osten besitzt seine Streitkräfte gehören
zu den 20 stärksten der Welt und
übertreffen in einigen Bereichen sogar
die Israels trotzdem sind die USA immer
noch die mit Abstand führende
Militärmacht der
[Musik]
Welt falls ihr treue Zuschauer von
visualpolitik seid wisst ihr dass ankels
Streitkräfte zwar nicht in Bestform sind
aber immer noch praktisch unschlagbar
daher ist es nicht gerade verrückt zu
denken dass sie wichtige iranische
Einrichtungen wie Waffen und
drohenproduktionsanlagen oder
Urananreicherungsanlagen leicht
zerstören könnten allerdings müssten die
USA sehr vorsichtig vorgehen denn es ist
sehr wahrscheinlich dass die Kosten
ihres möglichen Eingreifens die Vorteile
bei weitem übersteigen würden und warum
fragt ihr euch nun wenn die USA
eingreifen würden würden sowohl der Iran
als auch seine Verbündeten wie z.B die
hisballah nicht zögern die
US-Stützpunkte in der Region und Israel
schnell und direkt anzugreifen aber
nicht nur das es bestünde auch die
Gefahr dass der Iran die Straße von
Hormus komplett sperrt und damit
möglicherweise eine weitere schwere
Energie und Wirtschaftskrise
auslöst tja und da habt ihr es meine
Lieben Zuschauer die Beziehungen
zwischen dem Iran und den USA sind seit
mehr als 40 Jahren feindselig und haben
sich in den letzten Jahren immer weiter
verschlechter das iranische
Atomwaffenprogramm die Unterstützung
putinrusslands in der Ukraine und jetzt
die Drohung Israel anzugreifen haben die
Beziehungen zwischen den beiden auf den
Tiefpunkt gebracht Analysten sprechen
bereits von der Möglichkeit dass die USA
notfalls im Iran intervenieren könnten
sie haben die militärische Stärke und
die Unterstützung Israels in Nahen Osten
aber ehrlich gesagt wäre das kein
Spaziergang im Moment scheint der Iran
seine Drohung noch nicht wahrzumachchen
obwohl Israel massiv gegen die Hamas in
Gaza vorgeht aber nur die Zeit wird
zeigen wann der kitpunkt kommt und der
Iran seine Drohung wahr macht und ob die
USA dann darauf reagieren werden wir
werden weiterhin am Ball bleiben und in
der Zwischenzeit seid ihr an der Reihe
würde es den USA gelingen den Iran
effektiv anzugreifen kann ankelsem
eigentlich neben der Ukraine
gleichzeitig auch Israel mit Geld und
Militärhilfe überholfen und könnte dies
auch den Ausgang des Konflikts in der
Ukraine beeinflussen wie immer sind wir
auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon gespannt ich hoffe dass euch die
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt
uns bitte ein Like teilt mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert es auch mit
ihnen vergesst bitte auch nicht das
tolle 1 plus1 black week Angebot von
Holzkern über den Link unter dem Video
in Anspruch zu nehmen nicht vergessen es
gilt nur vom 14 bis 20 November
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jeder Zeit
über eine Spende von euch mit uns h
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr ebenfalls in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis
[Musik]
bald